this new 2019 5k iMac is packin a 5
gigahertz eye 9 processor Vega 48
graphics in 64 gigabytes of RAM that we
saved six hundred and eighty dollars on
by upgrading it ourselves
we have links of those Ram sales in the
description below and we also have a
step-by-step tutorial guide on how to
install it yourself with all that
performance many people are wondering if
you can actually play high-end games
like fortnight battlefield 5 and Forza
horizon 4 on it with decent frame rates
using Windows boot camp so let's find
out now before you head to the comments
section explaining that the imac is a
ripoff compared to a Windows gaming PC I
want to mention that this is really only
meant for people who need a high-end
iMac for work or business and want to
play some games on the side without
spending a bunch of extra cash on a
gaming PC before we get into some games
let's quickly compare some gaming
benchmarks to the 2017 iMac pro the 2019
5k iMac is really close to the gaming
performance of the pro now testing the
same unit in heaven benchmark in Windows
10 we actually see a huge difference in
performance showing Jes how much more
optimized Windows is for gaming compared
to Mac OS alright so moving on to
another gaming benchmark we've got 3d
marks time spies so let's go ahead and
run it
all right so time spy just finished and
we got a score of 5237
and I'm looking back on my notes here
and the iMac pro actually got five
thousand seven hundred and ninety seven
so this is actually not too far off from
the iMac Pro so the firestrike benchmark
just finished and we got a score of
thirteen thousand five hundred and
eleven compared to fifteen thousand six
hundred and three on the iMac Pro so
it's definitely not quite as fast but it
is getting close so we're gonna go ahead
and jump into fortnight 5k resolution 51
twenty by twenty eight eighty epic
everything let's show the FPS alright so
frame rates are not looking good
seventeen eighteen Cal bring it down a
medium at 5k any different whoa there
you go
drop it down to like thirty nine forty
eight
just hit him there oh you got me all
right so we're bringing it down 3841 by
2160 basically 4k resolution brought it
to epic instead and now we're still
getting around 30fps 3843 close enough
hi everything still not great not where
you'd like to be to be honest 2560 by
1440 that's 1440p and we're gonna try
out epic everything let's go ahead and
get into the game and we're sitting at
around 55 to 60 fps Wow got him both Oh
get out of there guys
oh we got me I'm over there bring
everything down to high and let's see if
we can get a consistent 60 yep we're at
over 70 right now dropping down a little
bit to like 69 there we are at 85 87 95
Wow okay and guys if you're wondering
what mouse I'm using this is actually a
really great gaming mouse I'm linking it
in the video description below what's
special about it is that it doesn't use
bluetooth it actually comes with its own
dedicated chip that you plug into the
USB port so the latency is extremely low
it's almost like a wired mouse so you're
not getting that Bluetooth latency we're
staying above 60 all the time guys these
are the best settings for this iMac for
playing for at night 1440p high settings
alright guys next up is battlefield 5
1440p just like we had it before and
let's start off with ultra got'em
got another guy
oh I almost had him you guys see that
I'm gonna bring down the settings - hi
got him got one guy I see that Oh
so we're Oh yep
got him got one more got him Oh headshot
you guys see that well let's get this
guy
oh come on reload yeah
works great Oh Scott - guys see that got
him I hit him
got him whoa you guys see that
boom so with that let's get into our
final game Forza horizon for 1440p
everything is on altra 65 FPS Wow it's
actually really good let's go Wow
yes 65 it's super consistent 68 69 70 72
yeah the frame rates are incredibly
consistent we're at Ultra everything at
1440p now we're dropping slightly below
59 60 it's not too bad yep 65 67 it's
super consistent there's no drop frames
I'm not feeling any drop frames no
weirdness going on it feels really good
right we're at 4k now let's do 4k high
4k now at high and we're getting around
48 50 the frame rates are consistent so
you don't get a lot of weird dropped
frames glitches or anything like that I
think throughout all of these games if
you want to get a consistent 60fps
you're gonna have to play at 1440p so on
this map we're dropping down a 38 39 now
lots of trees everywhere that's probably
why nice sit I actually hit 50 right
there
52 not too bad it did drop into the 30s
though which is unfortunate you
definitely don't want that on this one
we're gonna actually 5756
down to 47 45 so this one varies a
little bit more why are you racing in a
truck man get out of here
alright one guy in front of me see it's
not perfectly smooth but there you go
first place well there you have it guys
there's some gaming on the 2019 5k iMac
with the i-9 processor and the Vega 48
graphics as you guys could see 1440p is
the best option if you're gonna be doing
gaming on this machine if you get into
4k the FPS starts to drop below 50 below
60 so if you're really trying to get a
good experience 60fps is where it's at
playing at 1440p through all of these
graphically intensive games so let me
know what you guys thought about this
gaming video in the comment section
below make sure you subscribe for more
videos like this one and we'll see you
in the next video
Oh headshot you guys see that